you're registered your bags are packed
and you want to get into those sessions
before they fill up which they will but
what do you do where do you even start
how about Ops it operations is an area
with some of the most potential for
generative AI assistance from automating
routine tasks to predicting and
preventing potential issues the
possibilities are nearly endless but the
session capacity definitely is not and
for an even more hands-on experience be
sure to check out our trusted tester
program where you can be one of the
first to experience the human-centric
duet AI in Google Cloud the intent
driven Cloud experience is personalized
with IDE based code assistance code
explanation chat assistance and way more
so definitely go check it out because